[موسيقى]
نرحب بكل المشاهدين وكل ضيوف البرنامج
والذين تشاهدونهم على الشاشه يمكنكم ان
تتفاعل مع ما يقولون على صفحتنا على
فيسبوك او على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر
نقاش ناعم مباراه كره القدم بعد اقل من
ساعه من الان ويا لها من مباراه لقاء في
نصف نهائي كاس العالم بين المنتخب
وعوده الى السؤال كيف يمكن للانسان ان
يكون فنسيا وان يتعلق ببلده الاصلي ثم
لماذا هذا التهويل هذه المخاوف من فتره ما
بعد المباراه في الشونسي يفترض ان تكون
اجواء احتفاليه فرنسا او المغرب فلماذا
العنف في مثل هذه التظاهرات واسئله عديده
اخرى نطرحها على ضيوفنا ستكون ستكون معنا
او معنا من الرباط عزيزه
عنايه سيبها معنا من الدوحه موفد فرانس
فانت كاتشي وديعه في يعني مع اييه في
الاستوديو فريق خريفه وخليف
خليف فاروق خليفه وصحفي ورياضي ومعي ايضا
محمد مندور وهناقد وصحفي رياضي غني عن
التعريف ومعنا من اكادير غني عن التعريف
والاخر هشام الادريسي وهو مدرب كره قدم
ومحلل رياضي اهلا وسهلا اهلا بكم ابدا معك
يا عزيزه ناتج يعني كل ما اقترب موعد
المباراه
كل ما ازداد الضغط الدم
ههه كل ما ازداد الضغط صحيح وربما ما
يساعد هي هذه الامطار الغزيره التي تسببها
الرباط العاصمه همم منذ صباح اليوم وعلى
ما يعتبره الرباطيون والمغاربه عامه
فالمطر عاده هو فعل خير المغاربه مستعدون
لهذه السهره الكرويه يعتبرون انها مباراه
مهمه مباراه تاريخيه ومباراه القمه كما
يقول العديدون ما يذكرنا به المشجعون هنا
هو ان زئير الاسود قد ابك الاساطير وقد
يسكت كذلك سياحه الديك هذا المساء على
الاقل هذا ما تتمناه همم كل يعني كل ما ان
هو في ليس فقط في المغرب
[موسيقى]
تسمعون الموسيقى ورائي ههه
بدات بدات الاحتفالات بدات الاحتفالات هنا
قبل المباراه وسوف تتواصل خلال همم خلال
كل الليله اعتقد طيب
تسمعين توقعات اكثر من مغربي ومغربيه حسب
حول النتيجه ماذا يقولون ماذا يرددون هناك
خوف شوي من المنتخب الفرنسي هناك عزيمه
والقول بان المنتخب المغربي هو الذي سيفوز
ماذا تسمعينا عموما
ما اسمعه وما قاله وليد الرجراجي عندما
نسال الناس يقولون ديروا النيه اي امنوا
بهذا الفريق الكل يتحدث عن مواجهه قمه
ويقولون لقد فزنا ولا فزنا لم يكن مفاجاه
حتى الان وهم مستعدون لمواجهه ابطال
العالم فرحون بهذه المواجهه على فكره بسبب
اعترافهم بقوه الفريق الفرنسي وهذا ما
قاله كل المشجعين الذين التقينا بهم اليوم
لكن يقولونهم مستعدون للفوز وهناك من يذكر
هدفان مقابل لا شيء وسنرى ذلك بعد ساعه من
الان ههه ههه طيب وديع في عيني بعيده عن
التوقعات لديك في الدوحه بالتاكيد وديع ان
التشكيله الان نعرفها
والمفاجاه من الناحيه المغربيه مع اضافه
مدافع الى التشكيله التي ستواجه المنتخب
الفرنسي همم تعفي نايف اكرد الذي كان
مصابا لاعب ويست هام يونايتد لاعب
وينضم الى تشكيله ليس مكان المدافع الذي
كان عوضه في المباراه السابقه
همم نعرف ان المنتخب المغربي
[ضحك]
المنتخب
هو الذي كان سجل خطا في مرمى امام امام
كندا همم
على دلكه فقط هنا معي لاعب مشجع كنت اريد
ان اقول لك ان نساله عن تكهناته
انا من لبنان جدا باريس بس لشجره
اعتقدته مغربي
وطياره جبت الصبح دفعت كل اللي يحضر
المغرب
همم وان شاء الله بنربح وبنروح على فرنسا
طبعا همم
حول التشكيله وانت سمعت ما يقولوا اخذتها
عن نقطه القوه الفريق المغربي ولكن نقاط
قوه كبيره ايضا عند المنتخب الفرنسي
فعلا تشكيل مفاجاه اخيه نصارحتنا اليوم
اول مره يغير وليد وليد الناقد الوطني
للمنتخب
مغربي الذي هو طموح اكبر وممكن ان يصنع
مره اخرى التاريخ من بابه الواسعه مستجدات
اسمه في مباراه النهائيه لكاس العالم ضد
منتخب عالمي وداعب متميزه وميسي وكل هذا
الذي تجعل من طرف الوطني المغربي اكثر
رغبه اكثر
السيارات مغربيه
كنت واقفه منه
مجنونه لكننا نريد الوصول الى نهائي كاس
العالم وانا لا اقول ذلك فقط
بلجيكا وكرواتيا واسبانيا والبرتغال نحن
نواجه افضل منتخب في العالم لكننا نركز
على ما نريد تحقيقه لدينا طاقه هائله
اليوم هذا سوف يدفعون غدا انها مباراه
خروج المغلوب عندما تكون لديك الرغبه ودعم
الجمهوري يمكنك الفوز بها انا مدرب مغربي
واحب بلدي واركز على المباراه
سيلي كيفك
افضل من اي فريق اخر لديهم افضل دفاع في
البطوله انه منظمون بشكل جيد للغايه
ويحافظون على تنظيمهم بشكل جيد ولديهم
ايضا بعض المهاجمين جدا عند الارتداد لذلك
كانوا فاعلين للغايه ايضا عندما تقدموا
للامام لقد شهدنا جميع مباريات المنتخب
المغربي
[موسيقى]
سكان هذا الحي الذي ترعرع فيه
سادعم المغرب خاصه لكونه فريق افريقي
ويقوم بانجاز تاريخي وهذا الامر لا يحدث
كل يوم لقد فازت فرنسا من قبل بكاس العالم
لذا سنقوم بدعم وليد الركراكي انه رجل
عظيم وابن مدينتنا لذلك علينا ان ندعمه لا
يوجد لدينا خيار اخر
سواء
من النادي الاهلي
لكنها ستكون المره الاولى بالنسبه للمغرب
انا اكثر مع المغرب لكنني احب فرنسا
المغرب بصدد القيام بانجاز تاريخي
ان يصل الى هذه المرحله هو شيء جميل
لكن على الجانب الاخر يتارجح قلبي لانني
عشت دائما في فرنسا
ههه
لكنني اريد ايضا ان تذهب فرنسا الى ابعد
نقطه ممكنه في هذه البطوله لذلك من الصعب
اخبارك بالفريق الذي اشجعه لكن بصراحه اود
ان يصنع المغرب التاريخ
محمد بندور صاحيه
انا استاذ المغرب
هشام الادريسي مع ان الحديث عن الكره
ثقيله
مبدئيا ما حدش كان متوقع عن المغرب ممكن
تصل الى ما وصلت اليه همم خلينا نكون في
منتهى طبعا الجميع كان منتظر مشاركه مشرفه
مشاركه جيده ولكن ليس الوصول الى الدور
قبل النهائي وقب قوسين او ادنى من الوصول
للمباراه النهائيه وبالتالي هو انجاز كبير
جدا لكره القدم الافريقيه والعربيه واعتقد
ان اخواتنا نفسهم في المغرب لم يكن
يتصوروا هذا الانجاز ولكن الان نحن في
الواقع نتحدث عن المباراه الواقع بيقول
ايه الواقع بعد لحظات ان انت ستخوض مباراه
راس مع المنتخب الفرنسي اينعم هناك همم
فروق فنيه يعلمها الجميع لصالح المنتخب
الفرنسي ولكن ما احنا كان في فروق ضد
المنتخب البرتغالي فاروق ضد المنتخب
الاسباني ومع ذلك المنتخب المغربي فلما
لانرر هذا الامر للمره الثالثه اعتقد ان
التشكيله اللي لعب اللي بيبدا بيه وليد
رجلي المباراه هو تشكيل ليس اا دفاع بحث
كما يتصور ولكن هو هدفه ايقاف مصادر
الخطوره في المنتخب الفرنسي وهم الجناحين
المنتخب الفرنسي بينتج مبابي وعثمان
ديمبلي بيمتلك سرعات قويه جدا وان كان
عثمان ديمبلي لاعب جناح كلاسيكي شويه من
الاجنحه اللي بتلتزم بالخط ولكن الببيله
وضعيه ثانيه مختلفه ولابد من وضع اكثر من
لاعب لمواجهته ولابد من عمل كتله الملك لا
يكفي واحد فقط لمواجه هو اسرع واقوى لاعب
موجود في الجناح حاليا في العالم كله
وبالتالي مواجهته بتستلزم وجود لاعب مساند
للمدافع الايمن ايمن حسام لا اشرف حكيم
تفضل الخطه دفاعيه محمد
خمسه في في الخط الخلفي من ضمن الخطه
دفاعيه
لتوقيف مبابي القطار
المغربي
يلعب باسلوب يغلب عليه الطبع الدفاعي ولكن
اليوم هو له هدف مع حدد من المباراه وهو
ايقاف سرعه ايقاف سرعه المنتخب الفرنسي
اقوى في نظرك يعني اقوى من من اسبانيا
واقوم البرتغالي
يعني راح نشوف المنتخب المغربي للوراء
يعني مش عيبه هذه كره القدم
ايه رايك في ايه
عايز اسمع اغنيه
للضيوف ايضا اكيد
اضافه مدافع كل ذلك من اجل طبعا مواجهه
كيليان مبابي
المنتخب
مع مدافع سريع ايضا في مواجهه كيليان
مبابي هنا اشرف حكيمي الذي يعرف جيدا همم
يلعبان معا همم في باريس سان جيرمان
صديقين هو المكلف على همم من حيث المبدا
له مواجهه كيليان مبابي على همم الطرف
ولكن في نفس الوقت ممكن في وجود مدافع
اضافي انا حكيمي يهاجم ويشكل ايضا خطر في
ظهر خلفها خلفه مبابي ويحرم همم
الظهير الايسر اذا هناك همم ايضا همم ربما
همم ظرف مهم جدا غياب همم
وسط الذي هو ايضا يلعب على اليسار همم في
الوسط خلفها
واماما
ويساعد هذا الثنائي ايضا غياب هابيو ربما
همم
وخيار رجراجي على ما اعتقد هو سماح لي
حكيمي ان يهاجم على الطرف الايمن وان يحرم
باقي من مسانده همم اللاعبين الغائب
الذي سيكون عليه همم ان يركز على الدفاع
سؤال فقط
اريد البرنامج يعني هو برنامج رياضي يعني
وديع انت تعرف انه همم كنا نعرف انه حكيمي
همم
كيف تتوقع انه ما هو السلاح اللي استعمله
لتوقيف مبابي ما هي الكلمات اللي راح
يقولها له قبل المباراه
هناك مساله او جوبان حقيقه اولا ممكن ان
ننظر الى ما حصل في المباراه السابقه من
حيث المبدا ما فيه هو ايضا اسرع من كاي
الوكر وان كان لاعب سريع جدا كي الوكر
ولكن
بالنسبه لحكيمي هو ايضا لاعب سريع هذا همم
هذه المساله والمساله الاخرى عندما ترحنا
هذا السؤال تحديدا على وليد
اول من امس او امس تحديدا همم عشيه
المباراه اعجاب انا ليس لدي نصائح واعطيها
لحكيم حكيم يعرف افضل مني ويعرف هو كيف
يجيب همم
وكيف همم
هشام الادريسي اتفضل
طريقه حتى الطريقه التي اختاره وليد يعني
اذا طريقه 3 5 2 في البدايه ولكن ربما قد
تتحول الى خمسه اربعه كيلو لانه بيعرف
بانه اللاعب
مبابيين لاعبين عندهم السرعه وبقوه
الايجابيه وعندكم ملكات فنيه كبيره
المنتخب
منتخب فرنسا
الفرنسيه الفرنسيه
طيب طيب
ملاحظه واحده لو كان امكانيه عندك امكانيه
عندك سماعه حتى يكون صوتك افضل مما نسمعه
الان سيكون ذلك جيدا جدا لو عندك سماعات
فالمهم دائما برده احنا دائما بنتكلم عن
الكليان مبابي لكن
الخوف من مصيده ممكن يقع فيها المنتخب
المغربي وهي مصيده اثنين لاعبين همم يؤدي
بشكل ممتاز من بدايه البطوله واللي فيه
شروق لاعب بيعيش تقريبا ممكن تكون افضل
سنه كرويه في تاريخه من يوم رحيله من
النادي الارسنال اه بالضبط بيعيش سنه
ممتاز على صعيد الفني سواء مع الميلان او
مع المنتخب الفرنسي حاليا هو بيثير جنب
الاعلام وميسي في صداره هدافي البطوله
بيقدم مباريات جيده جدا هو محطه جيده كمان
للمنتخب الفرنسي واحنا دائما بدون في مصر
ايه مهاجم قاعد للساقطه واللقطه شخصيه
بالضبط النقطه الثانيه وهي انطوان جريزمان
انطوان جريزمان
برغم ان هو في اخر سنتين برده مش هو
اللاعب اللي احنا عارفين مباريات كاس
العالم ومع المنتخب الفرنسي عنده دور مهم
جدا في الملعب طوره ليس فقط توزيع كما
يتصور بالظبط كما يتصور الجميع هو بيؤدي
دور دفاعي بيؤدي دور هجومي المنتخب
المغربي حذاري ان هو يقع في هذا الكمين
التركيز على الكليان مبابي مهم التركيز
على سرعات عثمان ديمبلي مهم ولكن اوليفيرو
جريزمان مهم جدا جدا جدا ان هم يخلوا
بالهم من
جيرو اللي حقيقه انا يعني مستغرب من هذه
اللعب دائما انت حتى من فرنسا ينتقدوا
جيرو بانهم فتره معينه عميرها
في المنتخب الفرنسي
على هذا اللاعب انا شفنا يعني تقريبا
مباراه صعبه اول مره
فيه تكافؤ يعني ولو انه فيه افضليه
المنتخب الفرنسي ولكن ممكن المنتخب
المغربي
باضافه لاعب اخر رح يغطي يعاون المزراوي
وحكيمي اييي الى انه المنتخب المغربي ممكن
يصنع مفاجاه طيب وديع وكنت اسمعك وانت
تتحدث مع رئيس النشر اتفضل
نعم فقط اضافه بالنسبه
للتحدث
الفرنسيه قبل اللحظات يقولون مع اضافه
مدافع همم في همم في الخلف همم يسمح ذلك
طبعا لظهرين ايه يهاجما على الطرفين ويسمح
ايضا للجناحين اي زياش وبوفان الذين لاعبه
على الاطراف في المباراه
بشكل مختلف الان يعني بطريقه ربما خمسه
اثنين واحد بمعنى زياش وابو فال يمكن ان
يتغطى على وسط الدفاعي الفرنسي همم
ينفرد وحده في الهجوم في مواجهه ثلاثه
مدافعين همم كلام بالنسبه لبعض المحللين
هنا يعتبرون انا
الان همم الى جانب انه سوري او خلف
بين الخطين
في عيان الفرنسيين الدفاع والوسط الدفاعي
شكرا
المنتخب المغربي سيطرك الكره والملعب
للمنتخب الفرنسي اليمنيه يع
لم بها القوه دياله وهو في الهجمات
المرتده والهجمات السريعه والكرات الثابته
لما كتكون عنده عمليه تنظيم الكره من
الخلف كيوجد مشاكل خصوصا اذا كانت الكتله
الدفاعيه يعني متلاحمه خطوط متراقبه
والممرات بين اللاعبين انه سيلعب بطريقه
خمسه اربعه واحد حتى لا تكون هناك اريحيه
عند يعني
يجد الحلم
ثم كذلك الدعم وصلت
المنتخب المباراه
المنتخب المغربي بالكافه اللاعبين ديالو
ثبت على انه منتخب يقارع الكبار والدليل
وايطاحته بمنتخب بلجيكا اسبانيا
عن الملعب لان الان وصل الخبر حاله دخول
ديدوشو وحاله سمع فقط ذوي صفرات الجمهور
يعني ان الملعب بالكامل هو ملعب تقريبا
مغربي هذا يلعب همم
متفرج همم جمهور المغربي همم بيحتل حوالي
50,000 من السعر الرسميه
وباقي ال 15,000 همم
الفرنسيه همم اعتقد ان همم المنتخب
المغربي سيشعر اليوم وكانه يلعب في مركب
محمد الخامس في في مثل هذه المواعيد يعني
هذه المباراه خاصه لما تلعب ضد الجزائر
والمغرب وتونس
الجمهور عنده دوره كبير
على المباراه هل المنتخب المغربي بدنيا
جهاز مئه بالمئه مثل ما شفناها في
البرتغال لانه لما تدافع تتعب اكثر من
منتج الان السؤال المطروح هل جاهزيه
البدنيه للمنتخب المغربي هل هو جاهز يعني
الفيزيك مو هل هو جاهز
يوقف منيح المنتخب الفرنسي ولا واحد يعني
مهم جدا
دائما في هذا الامر يعني انا عندي وجهه
نظر صحيح اه انا عندي وجهه نظر في هذا
الامر في مثل هذه المواعيد الكبرى
والمباراه هذه المباريات المهمه دائما لما
يكون الروح
عليها عامل كبير جدا في هذه المواجهات
بمعنى ان انا قادر ان انا استخرج 110 او
120% من
البدنيه في مواجهه لاعب همم يعني بيخرج
100% فقط وبالتالي الروح والتماسك
والتعاون واللعب بتلاحم واللعب ككتله
واحده يعوض الفروق انا اجزم ان المنتخب
المغربي ليس من الان ولكن من المباراه
السابقه عنده بعض المشاكل البدنيه والدليل
غياب مزراوي غياب نايف اكرد وبعض اللاعبين
اللي كانوا مجهدين وخرجوا من المباراه زي
همم ولكن ما عوض الفريق المغربي هو
التماسك وهو الصح طيب اتفضل اتفضل هذا
السؤال المهم بانه انا متفق مع الاخوان
الاعزاء لان المنسوب البني ادم الفريق
الوطني
القناه لاعبات بلاعبينا متغيرين منهم
العبي كل المجموعه ولكن الفريق الوطني
المغربي حافظ على توابته اليوم انا اقول
واجزم على انه فعلا لما تكون انت يعني
التي تدافع فتستفيد مجهود بدني اكبر لانك
تجري وراء الكره يمينا ويسار تتمايل هنا
وهناك اكثر مما تكون تملك الكره ولكن يبقى
ان الفريق الوطني المغربي بدرجه
100%
فقط من اجل الروح من اجل ارضاء الجماهير
من اجل اللاعب للوطن وهدف حد ذاته معنوي
اكبر للاعبين اكبر ويكونوا في المستوى
اللي كانت منه وما انهم حاولوا ما امكنه
يوزعون مجهود بدني لهم عبر المباراه يعني
بشكل جيد حتى لا تكون هناك مشاكل عضليه
للاعبين وتكون تغييرات طائر هشام هشام
سؤال فقط يعني همم اليوم لما بتوع الجانب
البدني هل يعني المباراه بعد بعد لحظات
المباراه هي اللي راح تعطينا الجواب هل
المنتخب المغربي جاهز ام لا سؤال هو كيف
استرجع المنتخب المغربي في هذه الايام
الماضيه بثلاث او اربع ايام كيف استرجع ما
هو الدور يعني نستثني الركراك يعني الدور
الطاقه الطبي كيف كيف كان استرجاع من
الناحيه النفسيه من الناحيه البدنيه هذه
العوامل في في في في تالق المنتخب المغربي
اليوم ضد فرنسا اذا تاهل
فعلا انه انت تعرف اخي هو انه بعد قبل هذا
المعسكرات المجمعه تكون هناك يعني تمارين
اعداديه خاصه فيها قوه التحمل فيها السرعه
في القوه الانفجاريه مما تدخل للمباريات
يعني من كل ثلاث ايام مباريات يتغير الوضع
وتصبح فقط تبحث على يعني طراوه البدنيه
والسرعه
بان الفريق الوطني المغربي المباراه بعد
اخرى يزيده بانه يبدا المجهود اكبر ولكن
عمليه استشفاء عمليه اعاده ثقال اللاعبين
عمليه الاستغلال على العامل النفسي اعطاء
يعني اللاعبين المناكين بدنيا كل هذه
العوامل هذه تعطيني الفريق الوطني المغربي
اليوم الجاهزي على ان يكون اللاعبون يعني
اعطاهم اكثر من هذا وهناك من اللاعبين هم
طلبوا وليد على لاعب المباراه رغم ان وليد
يعلم بانهم غير جاهزين يعني 100% كما كان
في البدايه ولكن لديهم طموح لديه رغبه
وبالتالي سيد بيقول لنا الجهد من ان يكون
الفريق الوطني المغربي جاهز من دقيقه
الاولى وحتى المنتخب الفرنسي حتى المنتخب
الفرنسي فهو بدل جود كبير لانه عفاحه
بانجلترا في مباراه لعبت فيه القوه
البدنيه دور كبير اعتقد نفس الشيء بالنسبه
لمنتخب فرنسا انما الفارق بين المنتخب
فرنسا لاعبين استانسوا مع هذه الاجواء ومع
هذا يعني التواجد في نصف نهائي كاس عالميه
والمنتخب المغربي لاول مره بلاعبي يا شباب
طموحين قادرين على خلق الخالقين ان شاء
الله طيب طيب طيب هشام نريد ان ندخل نوعا
ما في الجانب لان هذه المباراه سوريا
حتى ايمان ماكرون على تويتر منذ قليل
الحديثيا بملك المغرب محمد السادس قبل هذه
المباراه
سيحضر هذه المباراه في يده حتى يتابع هذه
المباراه ولكن على على تويتر يقول طبعا
همم جميعنا همم وراء الفرق
اجري اعلان انتصار دون ان ننسى ان الرياضه
تجمعنا قبل كل شيء في ثار الاحترام
والصداقه بين الشعبين هشام هل تتفهم كل
هذه المخاوف ماذا كيف قرات انت هذا
التوظيف السياسي خاصه من قبل اقصى اليمين
لمساله الانتماء للاعبين بالحديد لان
كثيرين منهم ولدوا في فرنسا ويحملون
الجنسيه الفرنسيه وجنسيات اوروبيه
جلاله الملك محمد السادس وهو يحتفل مع
ابناء شعبه في التاهل التاريخي يعني هو
كثير من الدلائل فالمغرب ارسل كثير من
الرسائل عبر كاس العالم ربما خرجت على
النطاق الرياضي ودخلت في نطاق الانساني
ضرب به المثل
في التعاون في كذلك صله الرحم في بر
الوالدين بالتعامل مع الاشخاص واعتقد بين
الحقيقه العرب في قطر اثبتوا على ان
اللحمه العربيه حاضره وعن الكلب مصلحه
المغرب لان المغرب اعطى صوره على كره
القدم العربيه على كره القدم بالخليجي
بافريقيا وهدف حددته انجاز
وبالتالي ان كل هذا يعني هذا الكلام ربه
لن يدخل في نطاق المباراه
الرياضه
وان يتمتع بها كل من يدخل في هذا المنظومه
الرياضيه كره القدم التي اصبحت لغه العالم
واعتقد بان ما شاهدناه من مواقف من صور
ومن فيديوهات ربما تعطينا دروس على ان
الانسانيه فوق كل اعتباره على ان كره
القدم خلقت من اجل الاخلاق من خلف من اجل
الرياضه ومن اجل بعث رسائل القيم اخلاقيه
للمجتمع والكون
بكامله طيب محمد بندوره ولكن لا يمكن ان
ننسى لا يجب ان ننسى بانه تم نشر الالاف
من رجال الشرطه طبعا حتى وسائل النقل
توقفت خاصه على جده
بعض المدن منعت حتى بعد الاحتفالات ومنعت
بعد المدى قامت حتى بمنع بعد الاحتفال
هناك ما خوف حقيقي
حماقي في الطبيعي ان يكون في مخاوف لان
انا الحياه كنت موجود في الشنزليزيه بعد
مباراه البرتغال والمغرب بساعه تقريبا
وشويه شهاده يعني كان هرجه امراه كبير جدا
زحام كبير جدا ما كانش في الحقيقه اعتداء
على ممتلكات العامه
ولكن الزحام قد ينتج عنه اشياء غير لطيفه
غير ظريفه وللاسف الشديد البوليس الفرنسي
احيانا بتعامل مع هذا المشهد احيانا ببعض
العنف احيانا الطبق الاحداث احيانا بيكون
في رد فعل مغاير لما في الواقعه وبالتالي
احنا بنستفز هنا الطرف الاخر اللي همم
واضح من ال- ال- المشهد بالكامل انه نزل
الى الشوارع للاحتفال وليس لها افعال اخرى
همم وجهه نظري ان لابد ان يكون هناك
احتفال في حاله الفوز في حاله مهما كمان
مهما كان فرنسا ولكن لابد ان احنا همم
يكون لنا صوره جيده نعبر عن انفسنا بشكل
جيد مش لازم نستفز الاخر مش لازم يكون في
ردود على عنيفه اتجاه الاخرين مش لازم همم
نخرب بلد احنا كلنا عايشين فيها
وبناكل منها وبيوتنا مفتوحه منها ده بوجهه
نظري الشخصيه البحته مع احترامي للجميع
مهما كانوا العرب ما الموجودين في فرنسا
فتبقى فرنسا بلد حاضنه لكل الجنسيات ومهما
كان التاريخ بقى اللي من 50 سنه و60 سنه
وللجميع بيتحدث عنه هو اصبح من التاريخ
ولا بد ان نتعاش مع الواقع اللي بيقول ان
فرنسا حاضنه لكل هذه الجنسيات حاليا كبير
يعني همم له فرنسا في الحقبه همم
في العقود الاخيره على كل
كل المجتمعات مهما تغير جنسيتها لكن
السؤال المطرح ما تدور توفيق لما تشوف
يعني واحد نخبه يغذي التطرف ب- همم تويتر
همم بين همم الاخوه يعني اللي همم او
المواطنين اللي عايشين في في بلد واحد همم
اللوم على هذه النخبه يعني هي اللي همم
ربما هي اللي تكون واجهه همم
مثل الاحداث الرياضيه اليوم المباراه
فرنسا المغرب الجمعي يتحدث عن هذه
المباراه همم اعتقد بانه اليوم يجب ان
تتغير ال- ال- ال-
منفتح اكثر همم
لما يشوف وسائط التواصل الاجتماعي يجب ان
يكون خطاب اخر خطاب لين همم خطاب يعني فيه
كثير من همم من
المرونه يعني نبتعد عن التطرف لانه
المباراه في يعني جيران فرنسي مع همم
مغربي همم ممكن يشربوا قهوه مع بعض ويتفرج
المباراه مع بعض وبعدين هي مباراه كوره
لانه كل واحد بيدرس له بتاعه يعني لما
تشوف البعض انه يعني عنده شويه ثقافه
رياضيه ولكن همم يخرج عليه اطار رياضي
ويستعمل كلمات
واحنا ولازم نربح فرنسا بمهما كان
الثمانيه لغايه الان الامور تبقى في اطار
هالرياضي هنا يعني دور كما قلت يعني
الدوره النخب لازم يكون عندهم دور كبير
خاصه في مثل هذه الموعد ابدا انه خب- تلعب
دورا في هذا المجال يتم الادريسي في
المغرب
نعم انه خب تلعب دور في التوائع في هذا
المجال هو ان تبقى في النهايه كره قدم
وتبقى في النهايه رياضه ونروح رياضيه هي
التي تسود
بالروح الرياضيه وتعاملنا كثير من
المباريات بنفس المنطقه
الذي تربى عليه كل المغاربه لا شيء لا عيب
ان يكون هناك يعني مغربي وفرنسي يتفرجاني
في مباراه المنتخبين كيفما كان الحال وكيف
ما كانت نتيجه المباراه نحن المغاربه
سنحتفل لاننا حقنا الانجاز ووصلنا لاول
مره في تاريخ كره القدم العربيه
والافريقيه الى نصف نهائي كاس العالم
سنلعب معها يعني فرنسا حتى ولو قدر الله
يعني حقق المنتخب الفرنسي التاهيل فسنه
يعني على هذا الفوز وكذلك سنحتفل معه
لاننا لاعبنا ضد ابطال العالم اما احنا
حققنا نحن تاهيل فسيكون احتفال اخر وبقع
من اخر لان المغاربه يتقون ويتمنون ويدعون
الله تعالى على ان يكون المغرب طرفا في
مباراه النهائيه ضد منتخب ارجنتيني وضد
لاعبين متميزين عالمي اسمه ميسي طيب هل
تقر مثل كثيرين بان المنتخب السعودي هو
الذي كسر هذا الحاجز وهذه العقده التي
كانت لدى الفرق العربيه والافريقيه بانه
من الصعب التغلب على فرق كبيره وطبعا
هزيمه الارجنتين امام السعوديه هي التي
كانت حافزا لفرق افريقيه وعربيه واخرى بان
تحقق مثل هذه النتائج
واولا ان المنتخب السعودي لانه يعني ربما
حققت الانجاز وان فاز على منتخب
الارجنتيني في اوجه عطائه انما التاريخ
يسجل على ان المغرب يعني فاز على منتخبات
كبرى وكان اول منتخب عربي تاهل الى كاس
عالميه للدور الثاني وفاز على كذلك منتخب
البرتغال بثلاثه لواحد في اوج عطاء منتخب
البرتغال ثم جاء بعد الدور على منتخب
نيجيريا ومنتخب السنغال وكذلك المنتخب
الجزائر
كل الدروس من اجل ان يكون المغرب يعني في
المحفل العالمي يعني في ظروف امنه لان حتى
امراء مشكورين دوله قطر الشقيقه يعني اعطى
دروس في الدعم والمسانده وكذلك
الدعم اللام مشروط للمنتخب المغربي وانا
جد كيف ان فرحه يعني الامراء
والعربيه ستتواصل ان شاء الله بالاجازات
على جميع المستويات همم ههه ظن بانوا
المباراه المرجعيه الافارقه والعربيه
مباراه ملحمه خيخون الجزائر المانيا
المانيا كانت بطله العالم في 82
وصلت للنهائي كان المنتخب الايطالي هو
اللي فاز باللقب نضل المباراه المباراه
الافريقيه
كثيره
فقط بانو المباراه
الفريق الوطني
بيفكر في مرحله ما بعد المال وكل لاعب
يطمح لكي يكون في فريق عريق في اوروبا ولو
ان عددا كبيرا من من المنتخب المغربي عدا
كبير من اللاعبين يوجدون في اوروبا
يعني المنتخب المغربي يمتلك دائما مجموعه
لاعبين متواجدين دائما في اكبر الانديه
الاوروبيه باستمرار سنوات الماضيه سواء من
المولودين في السعوديه
ده حق طبيعي
طموح فردي بعيدا عن الطموح الجماعي الكبير
للمنتخب المغربي في الفوز وتخطي في جماعه
طبعا كل لاعب بيدور بعد انتهاء كاس العالم
ولحد اربع سنوات مقبله هو هيكون فين
هينتقل من فين هيلعب فين هيؤدي ازاي هيهدف
فين النهارده حكيم زي ايش كان حكيم زي ايش
كان بيعاني بشكل كبير جدا
وارد جدا ان هذه البطوله تكون نقطه تحول
كبيره في تاريخ حكيم شويه كم من لاعبين من
قبل تحولت همم حياتهم بالكامل بعد بطولات
كاس عالم او بطولات اوروبيه سواء بالسلب
او بالاجابه فالحاله التي عليها المنتخب
المغربي
من استثمارها بالاجاب سواء لللاعبين لاعب
مثل يوسف نصيري كان يعيش في مرحله شك مع
فريقه مع فريق اشبيليه او مع او مع
المنتخب حتى في بدايات المونديال وكان
هناك بعض الشكوك لماذا يلعب يوسف مسيري
لماذا لا يلعب عبد الرزاق لماذا لا يلعب
وليد فاثبت في يوسف نسيبي انه لعيب مهم
ولعيب جيد ووارد جدا ان البطوله تحول مجرى
حياته الكرويه للافضل عند حين العوده
للفريق اشبيليه كذلك ياسين بونو ياسين
بونو الكل يعني حارس بصراحه الكل يعلم انه
اسبانيا يعني
بالضبط في ياسين بيقول النهارده مرشح
لانديه كبيره النهارده في لاعب العالم كله
يتحدث عنه
النهارده لما يخرج لويس انريكي في عقد
مباراه المغرب واسبانيا ويتحدث يا ولد
الاول ما له هذا الرجل هو لاعب صغير صغير
سنه سنه
الفرنسي اين كان هذا اللاعب من عيون
الانديه الكبرى
اين كان يعني دائما
الانديه الكبرى للاسف تبحث عن لاعبين
مشهورين لماذا لا تبحث عن نوعيه لاعب مثلا
زي كفاره سخيليا لاعب همم الجورجي حين
انتقل نادي نابولي اين اناحي اين لاعبي
اخرين مثلا اليوم
الاستثمار في هذا الامر وهذا الحدث مهم
سواء على الصعيد الفردي او على الصعيد
الجماعي بقى تسويق للجماعه المغربيه تسويق
للمنتخب المغربي واشياء مثل هذه وطبعا
واسعد انسان في الملعب سيكون طبعا هو امير
قطر لان عند ميسي في الارجنتين اشرف حكيمي
مع المغرب
وكلهم يلعبون مع باريس
لانها اما ان تفرح لبلدها بعد المباراه او
تحزن الحزن زوجها ههه
اذكر اللاعبين اللي راح يمضوا عقود اكيد
يعني ما في نقاش المنتخب المغربي
70% 60 70% اللاعبين راح يروحوا الدوريات
الكبرى الان توفيق يعني انجاز المغرب راح
يكون عنده همم
تاثيرات ايجابيه على يعني اقليميا عربيا
وحتى افريقيا اليوم نقدر نقول خريطه الكره
العالميه تغيرت نوعا ما لما تشوف المغرب
اليوم في الفاين في اول الفاينل يعني قلت
الفاينل ههه نصف نهائي ممكن يروح للنهائي
اليوم المنتخبات الاخرى العربيه الافريقيه
يجب ان تغير من سياستها يعني
المباراه بعقليه المنازل يعني لما تدخل
تواجه اسبانيا وانت انهزم اا اسبانيا راح
تفوز اليوم المنتخب المغربي غير موازين
همم موازين القوى نوعا ما في في الكره
العالميه هذا يحسب ل همم الركراكي
وبالحديث عن المدرسه في التدريب بدا
التخليل
النبي محمد
والاخلاق هي التي خلقت من اجل الرياضه انا
معي الان اللاعب حسين بن عياده لاعب منتخب
الجزائر اساسي
الفريق الوطني
السلام عليكم
سؤال اليوم في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
في هدف الكاميرا
الادريسي مدرب كره قدم
سعيد لكم جميعا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]